by the way I'm sick of the [ __ ]
burger places I know I've talked about
this before but I'll tell you right now
they asked me at the Q&A on the UCLA
thing they asked me what's the best la
meal and I go like this you know what
man if you're coming to me for a real LA
meal I don't a lot of people eat to live
a lot of people live to eat I don't live
to eat man that [ __ ] is fuel for me put
it in my mouth
I'll eat it it'll be quick and then I'm
about my business all right
so I'm about my business after I eat I'm
not [ __ ] numb them all but really on
num num I don't like I don't go to
restaurants if somebody says they're
good whatever I'll just go if it's near
if I like the ambiance you understand
all right so they asked me and I said
I'm not about this [ __ ] in and out dude
in and out if you ask me for a good Los
Angeles meal in and out that's it that's
what I'm thinking and that's what I'm
doing and I love in and out and when
people [ __ ] say by the way Theo put
up a thing the other day about how in
him in and out is not even that good and
I just to be totally interesting right
now I completely disagree with them and
that's that's [ __ ] interesting to
disagree with somebody who has a podcast
so he [ __ ] said that and I go like
this okay
alright by myself just alright okay and
I got mad by myself that he said that
and I was like okay alright whatever
dude and then I was like why I haven't
texted with him in a while since the
Kovich [ __ ] he jumped out of a [ __ ]
group chat that we were in which is
[ __ ] by the way dude he jumped with
jumps out of a group chat let me tell
you right now if you jump out of a group
chat you're [ __ ] [ __ ] for real you
do you let those dings come in or you
hide it or whatever the [ __ ] you know
how you could [ __ ] whatever you would
what do you call him Do Not Disturb or
whatever the [ __ ] that's [ __ ] I'm
tracking the group man there's a
[ __ ] in there that doesn't even
write he hasn't written since he's been
in the group chat and he's still
watching and I know he's watching and
sometimes we forget he's there we almost
talk [ __ ] about him but anyway dude no
in and out no way no way in and out is
so good and people like I but the fries
dude shut up
shut up man it's about the burger you go
to a burger place for a burger okay and
then
and then people are like oh yeah but
Shake Shack see that's the thing they
always come around with like some new
[ __ ] and it doesn't have the staying
power that in and out has people like to
say that like the new [ __ ] is better
because they want to be interesting and
I hate that [ __ ] you know
oh but have you heard of oh you like
that bin but have you heard of this man
I saw them play at the place and there
were only 12 people there but they're
the new one Oh bro congratulations the
[ __ ] Lewis and Clark
you found them that just means you were
you stumped you just were there dude
you're bragging about being somewhere
imagine how boring you got to be about
bragging about being somewhere and there
are [ __ ] out there talking
about that what with chain burger
restaurants they're like yeah but have
you tried Bluebird burger there's always
a new one with blue in it have you tried
Bluebird burger blue blue stone
have you tried blue tapestry have you
tried blue ribbon dude in and out yo
guess what we have [ __ ] I just turned
myself up in my headphones that's why
there's a little bit of a cut because
you know this is one take dude this is
just one take and it goes one take and I
don't cut [ __ ] out unless maybe I
[ __ ] talk to someone else
or about someone else and then I asked
them if I could put it in and they say
no but I think that's only happened one
time anyway whatever dude foreign on all
cylinders man so yeah so in and out is
the best burger and what we what people
people are just they don't want to be
loyal man they don't want to be loyal
dude people [ __ ] hate being loyal and
one of the number one things you ask if
you ask any random person down the
street hey what are your five biggest
qualities I guarantee number four will
be like oh but and also I'm loyal then
what the [ __ ] are you doing looking for
different burgers dude when I say in and
out is the [ __ ] I go to in and out I go
to in and out I go to in and out I go to
in and out
I go to internet I go to in and out and
then after a bunch of times I go to in
and out I go to in and out somebody says
do you want to try the new shake and I
say well why don't we stop right there
loyal [ __ ] I'm going to in and
out but I heard shake check is that's
fine I'll tell you what if I'm hungry
and I'm near a Shake Shack or I'm at the
airport and a Shake Shack is around and
I know there's no in and out I'll get a
shake shot but until then dude I'm in
and out man I'm in enough for life for
those that you doesn't know know in and
out isn't in that as a burger uh but
yeah so I'm loyal dude I'm not ever
looking for the different [ __ ] I figured
out what I like and that's what you got
to do it and people are like ah but it's
narrow-mindedness
oh yeah but I already [ __ ] thought
about all the other things people like
well don't you want to travel what if
you knit you never been to Taiwan is it
beautiful and I already thought about it
ah [ __ ] man
I'm not tired yet right I'm not gonna
lose steam dude